we're stuck oh my god so we get that
hello everyone I'm in Las Vegas right
now and when you think about Las Vegas
you think about the live shows we are at
Treasure Island right now we're in the
theater where Miss steer the Cirque du
Soleil show is put on you can see the
whole thing behind me it is a giant it
is incredible and I am very excited
because today I'm gonna be training like
the Cirque du Soleil performers I got
Eric with me we're gonna compete we're
gonna see who's better we're gonna tough
it out today actor versus athlete we're
gonna compete and see who can learn to
be a Cirque du Soleil performer also I
think we're getting fitted we're gonna
go and try on different costumes I'm
basically gonna become a part of the
show we're both grossly competitive so
if he tries to beat me I will kind of
sabotage him as much as possible all
right so we're going backstage now to
the greenroom
oh this is awesome hey guys I'm Spencer
I'm Gabriel costume is called our motto
so it's an iconic character to Mystere
you'll see that all throughout our show
mischievious sort of characters are sort
of third line throughout our show our
show is sort of about the creation of
life the creation of the flower in the
desert because you are the original
Cirque du Soleil show here on the strip
I have a really bad wedgie right now oh
there we go that wasn't as bad yeah kind
of good let's let's do it
[Music]
how about the but do you feel the butt
thing working yeah
oh my god one of our training rooms okay
now how do you get it back down you have
to push with your feet oh oh that's
pretty good form okay can you help me
get up there yes thanks okay it's weird
because now I can see two butts you're
real but your fake butt
[Music]
you guys still warm I'm warmed up let's
see what let's go to the stage let's try
some acrobatics I'm ready can you slow
down that is insane
he's like God okay you you ready to go
on stage and try this out yeah let's do
it
okay I don't think I can do this
got a 20 back okay we're looking at the
performer right now he's looking a Greek
god he is she's ripped as could be I've
never felt we're inferior in my life hey
man how you doing hello Eric
oh it's the system we can't wear this to
the flying costume indicate all right
we'll be right back thank you Mike Allen
never fit clean on me only thing nice
two chains on
[Music]
there we go I can't I'm pretty impressed
and I'm mad I'm proud of him but with
the competitive part of me as little man
that was so fast I know why I liked it a
quadruple million axel
[Music]
[Music]
is that how slow I was was that not good
I was doing so well no it was better oh
we've talked about this I'm a little
stronger than Eric I thought that would
help me but I think because I breakdance
I understand like momentum yeah like how
to create with my legs so we're gonna
have you try something else thank you -
Dima yeah thank you so much appreciate
it
spicy way right now okay so we're ready
for the second thing we got a whole new
wardrobe change and everything we're
wearing multiple layers underneath this
we got some faces on the back - holy
crap
is that what we're doing that that is so
tall you said you're scared to play yeah
a little bit okay and if there's any
more spinning hello I will definitely be
nothing I'm very impressed with what
you're doing already I think Spencer
might have an upper hand right now
because I'm still feeling very nauseous
so I hope that goes away and I can just
like get 150% on these poles that look
so much that's very hard video is just
me and Spencer their hand is like it's
proving that we are that we suck at
everything why we're unskilled I used to
watch these shows all the time and be
like I wish I could do that I think I
could go out there and do that yeah feel
good I can't do any of it no hands you
mad at me
yeah but did he lift your knee up no you
mad bro
[Music]
whoa that is absolutely impossible use
this so actually when you kick you want
to twist thing I'll do you got this last
routine oh this is the show there's live
audience now this is the performance
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow this is not your fault yeah awesome
early failing you guys did great
thank you thank you we have a little bit
more work before you already Thursday it
was a good effort I feel like the least
athletic person in the world before I
came in I thought it was gonna do pretty
good I thought that like my years of
training would help me but that is so
much harder than it looks I feel like
when you watch the show you're like wow
that looks so hard that's so impressive
yeah but like you really don't
understand how difficult it is like it
looks amazing but then the moment you
tried the most simple move in the show
and you can't even do that
it really like blows your mind when I
watch Cirque du Soleil shows it's gonna
be that completely different now Thank
You Cirque de Soleil this was an
incredible experience competition wise
we're both losers you have a lot of work
to do to get on their level years and
years of practice all right so we're
gonna go work out the training buddies
yeah we have a lot of work to do we got
to get a better edge here we're back
okay let's go trains go change my god
lean never fit clean Oh me only thing
nice is two chains on
playing dirty trying to switch on me
Bertie's show me